as much as we would love to be talking
about other things the number of
important developments
uh in the land of covet is so many and
the amount that rides not only on our
ongoing developing understanding of the
way coveted covert treatments work but
also on our ability to go back and
figure out what we got right and what we
did not have right
in the past
now
this week this episode we are going to
talk about a result
that has recently
emerged
in which the
two major types of vaccines for covid
that is to say the adenovectored
vaccines and the mrna lipid nanoparticle
vectored vaccines
were assessed
[Music]
with the measure of all-cause mortality
now that is an important thing to do and
the reason that it is an important thing
to do is that vaccines as we have
pointed out
hundreds of times maybe
are um basically an intervention into
a series of complex systems that series
of complex systems being
uh at least three layered you've got the
immune system which is complex system
inside of the critter that is the human
which is a complex system inside a
society of people in which a
pathogen
produces an epidemic so
all of these complex systems are going
to be affected by the various
interventions that we might
seek to deploy and their net effect is
what we ought to be interested in so
this recent study which is
technically not peer-reviewed yet which
means that it was not handed to
anonymous reviewers and
their comments then delivered back to
the editors and the editors then
deciding to publish it but what has has
been peer reviewed in fact by
martin kuldruff and colleagues who
looked through and reported on this uh
zach do you want to show the website
that i sent you martin wrote about
these vaccines
in any case
so
as you and i heather have been talking
about from the beginning of the pandemic
peer review does not mean review by
peers peer review is a
i would argue a kind of jargon that
obscures the reality in which
peers are anonymously given a paper to
review by editors
and the amount of skullduggery that
flies beneath the radar
under this banner of peer review
is great and while some of us oppose
this kind of peer review
none of us who are worth our salt as
scientists oppose the idea of peers
reviewing work but we think it would be
much better done uh out in the open
transparently um
yes i'm wondering if before you show
this article by uh ron koldorf
um
you want to just show the actual yeah i
think
um so here we have it uh
and called for those just listening
viewpoint randomized clinical trials of
code 19 vaccines do adenovirus vector
vaccines have beneficial non-specific
effects and just as a reminder although
most most listeners and viewers will
already recognize this
we have two main classes of vaccines
that at least at least in the weird
world
have been widely available the mrna
vaccines produced by pfizer and moderna
two different ones and the adenovirus
factored vaccine is produced by johnson
johnson which is the only adenovirus
factored vaccine that's been
allowed in the united states and then
also astrazeneca
right and so actually maybe we should
just do a little of the biology here
both of these kinds of vaccines are
novel um and the
miracle which is their rapid production
in the aftermath of kovid also presents
us with a problem which is that we've
got two platforms essentially in which a
vaccine can be manufactured now
apparently it can be done very very
quickly
that we know very little about we just
don't know what their effects are and
they work into
i would argue radically different ways
one of them takes an adenovirus and
basically implants a
antigen
or the message that produces an antigen
into this uh this virus which is capable
of infecting human cells
um
uh and the other one takes an mrna which
is a message that a cell natively
transcribes and introduces it into the
cell as if it had just come from the
nucleus and the cell then faithfully
transcribes and actually translates this
message into a protein which is supposed
to then lodge in the cell surface but in
the mrna case instead of being delivered
by a virus which has evolved to infect
human cells it is delivered by what's
effectively a pseudovirus which is a
coat of these lipid nanoparticles
and these lipid nanoparticles lipid
means fat and the lipid nanoparticles
because they are
uh composed of fat and because the
surface of all cells is made up of fat
based membrane causes it to fuse light
dissolves like and basically lipid
nanomark particles
touch a cell
the message is spilled in and then the
the ribosomes in the in the cytoplasm
translate the uh the message into a
protein which then gets displayed on the
surface of the cell hopefully and the
immune system
learns to recognize it
now you and i have talked at length
about the hazard of these new
technologies especially the lipid
nanoparticle one and the reason that the
lipid nanoparticle one has
caught our attention to something
particularly uh concerning
is that there is no specificity
whatsoever
in
where these lipid nanoparticles deliver
their message they will deliver it to
whatever cells are most hospitable and
there is no reason to think that the
cells that are most usefully
delivered this message are the ones that
will pick it up it will
circulate you know in the
form that the manufacturers intended it
it's supposed to stay
effectively in the arm where it's
injected and it's supposed to be those
cells presumably the muscle cells which
pick it up right
and a critical distinction being that
whereas with traditional vaccine
technology
of which there are also two types and
one of which is more ancient than the
other as as you'll talk about but
attenuated um but still
live uh versus dead vaccines
in both of those cases the idea is we're
going to put something in your body
the goal of which is to get the
attention of your immune system so that
it can learn how to deal with such a
pathogen if it runs into it in its wild
type
and in this case
you
it is it is quite quite not that so it
is it is lacking specificity and uh the
expectation is not that in its in its
form in which it is injected the immune
system will recognize it although that
might also be the case but that it will
um move into cells and produce copies of
for the most part the spike protein and
um i just uh read a couple sentences
from the beginning of the introduction
here of this you want to say who the
authors are um
yes the authors are
uh i'm going to butcher most of the
names here christine ben frederick
schultz book culture sebastian nielsen
mahai netea i apologize and peter abbey
this again is the pre-print called
randomized clinical trials of covet 19
vaccines do adenovirus vector vaccines
have beneficial non-specific effects or
are we just a couple sentences from the
intro and then sort of the conclusion
out of the abstract even though
that's not usually the order in which
one shares stuff
introduction within the current
understanding of vaccines it is logical
to assume that covet 19 vaccines reduce
overall mortality corresponding to the
number of co-19 deaths prevented
okay
however there is now ample evidence that
vaccines can have broad heterologous
effects on the immune system these
effects can lead to additional
protection or increasing susceptibility
to unrelated infections or even other
non-infectious immune-mediated diseases
therefore as it has now been established
in numerous studies vaccines may have
completely unexpected effects on overall
mortality
different from what could be anticipated
based on the protection against the
vaccine-targeted disease that is an
excellent procedure right there of
uh basically the argument that then the
first author on the paper christine ben
makes in an interview with unheard that
you will also talk about the cheat that
she did this week for why unlike what
was done for instance in the trials that
pfizer ran uh
we should not be focusing on only
on
effect on that disease but overall
mortality all cause mortality to use the
term of art right so with and and
frankly it's easier it's easier to look
at all cars brutality because you don't
have to end up dithering as and
dithering minimizes the importance of
this but as many of us have have been
trying to figure out these last two
years and for many people maybe for much
longer than that like well you know in
the case of kovid it's only the last two
years two plus now um you know did she
die of covet or with covet and because
um you know especially now with omicron
being so highly transmissible and so
many people have had it or still have
evidence of it circulating um there are
it is quite clear quite a number of um
you know sometimes presumably
unintentional sometimes absolutely
intentional messing with the numbers
such that all of these deaths that are
attributed to covid are not actually
deaths that happened because of covid
but deaths that happened while the
person also was infected with kobe you
know people who entered hospital for
entirely other reasons were then tested
found to have cove and died for those
entirely other reasons and were listed
as having died of covet so all of that
um all of that problem is avoided if you
focus on all cosmetic all cause
mortality in those people who got um say
mrna vaccines versus adenovirus vaccines
and that's the comparison being made
here not to unvaccinate people um you
know was all cosmetic or that's not no
no no it's not it's not exactly right so
in these three groups is all cause
mortality um
you know better or better or worse
and uh the abstract uh reveals here can
we can we hold off can we lay a little
more groundwork okay then he shouldn't
be showing the screen yeah i mean
it's not a secret but uh
first of all this comes in the context
right and you hinted at that context but
i think that context
you have to understand it in order to
see
why a study like this is likely to tell
you something really important that you
might not know so
um
dr ben
talks about prior work which has
revealed a pattern i believe that
she and her team studied 10 vaccines
that are just part of the standard
schedule of vaccines for children
and the pattern that they found
was that the live attenuated virus
vaccines
tended to increase longevity they
decreased all cause mortality and the
all-cause mortality decrease could not
be attributed to the target disease
entirely itself could not entirely be
attributed to that exactly so for
example
in the case of the measles vaccine
there was a benefit in the reduction of
measles which did account for some
fraction of the reduction in overall
loss of life but it didn't account for
all of it not even close
so the point is there are non-specific
effects of these vaccines and we don't
entirely understand what they come from
one could imagine for example this is
one plausible example
that cross-reactivity because viruses
are related to each other being
vaccinated against one virus might
create immunity to another virus that
had similar
uh surface structure and for which maybe
we're not as familiar we don't have a
name yet we certainly don't have a
vaccine but now you've got right um some
some baseline immunity to something that
um the medical establishment isn't
formally looking out for right and it
doesn't have to be that direct it could
also be that because the immune system
exerts a selective pressure on the
viruses themselves viruses may come that
aren't closely related may come to
resemble each other because what they're
doing is they are evolving to be
invisible to the immune system and so
cross-reactivity doesn't even require
that the viruses be related but in any
case the basic point is if you look at
the attenuated virus vaccines
what you see is an all-cause mortality
benefit you get the exact opposite when
you look at the
killed virus vaccine so again these are
the two
broad types of vaccines that existed
before you know a couple years ago right
um now and what's an example of a killed
virus vaccine that we will
[Music]
um
but in any case i'm not i'm not going to
guess but uh the
the point is when
people who are dark horse listeners will
have heard the following logic discussed
by us here before
if you have an attenuated virus a live
virus
vaccine it do you have an answer
uh you know this is just
uh
this is off of a site called passport
health global so i'm not going to vouch
for it beyond that but some attenuated
live virus vaccines include mmr as you
said yellow fever oral polio vaccination
and oral typhoid
and some dead vaccines include
they say polio here and they're going to
mean not oral um cholera which all i
mean cholera is a crap vaccine
long before any of this like it's just
got really low efficacy influenza hep a
and typhoid and again it's the non-oral
typhoid
so um
the
the logic works something like this
when you get an attenuated virus vaccine
that is a living vaccine that is a
weakened form it doesn't make you sick
and hopefully it can't transmit from one
person to another right all bets are off
if something figures out how to jump
from one individual to another but a
attenuated virus that can infect cells
enough to give you a very mild infection
hopefully one that you can't even detect
you've got anything maybe you've got you
know your arm has a slight fever or
something like that for a day this sort
of thing yeah yeah um that because it is
an infection right causes the immune
system have the right reaction right
they work very well for this reason
they're also a little scary for this
reason because you're dealing with an
organism that
has heredity and therefore could evolve
it doesn't evolve very well if it
doesn't move from one person to the next
but as soon as
that trick gets introduced it's a very
different thing but in the case of a
killed virus
or a antigen from a killed virus a piece
of a virus that you're delivering to the
immune system the immune system
may spot it because it's foreign but it
doesn't look like an infection and so
the reaction is often very weak
so two things are true one
uh you may get more than one vaccination
in order to introduce the same antigen
multiple times which sort of simulates
an infection and two print trigger is
the goal here unlike in much of social
space now like you're trying to trigger
your immune system
what is this right but then the other
thing the thing that you and i have
talked about hey wait a minute what the
heck is this technology and whoever said
that was safe is the adjuvants and the
adjuvants are basically
immune irritants
immune irritants that cause the immune
system to react like there's an
infection which then raises all kinds of
questions about how good are they at
spotting the thing that the vaccine
manufacturer wants them to react to
versus the stuff that was involved in
the food that you ate
or your own tissues right in other words
annoying your immune system with an
adjuvant is basically an invitation to
the
inappropriate
activity of the immune system either in
the form of allergies or autoimmunity
and so anyway what
dr ben reveals in her in her interview
about this paper which is narrower is
that in this prior work the the the
answer came out pretty clear the
dead virus or pieces of virus the
antigen-based uh adjuvant containing
vaccines
reduced all redu reduced longevity
increased all-cause mortality and the
live virus uh vaccines
decreased all-cause mortality so so just
um
are
live also known as attenuated
virus vaccines inherently adjuvant free
do you know do you know the answer to
this okay i i know that that's the
general pattern i it may be a hundred
percent but
in any case so this so they have all
sorts of things going for them
right yeah so
and i mean this sorry but this just
reminds me and this is what we've been
saying from the beginning of covet and
the prospect of vaccines like oh goody
cool vaccines vaccines are one of
broadly speaking the three major
successes of western medicine
antibiotics and surgery being the other
two
and oh by the way
just because we call it a vaccine
doesn't mean it's awesome
and especially if we are in an
environment in which people are willing
to play all sorts of games with words
and slot anything over into vaccine
space oh and at the same time start
redefining what vaccine means and what
vaccination means and what anti-vaxxer
means well
there's just no ability to communicate
anything clearly and so
really it shouldn't be necessary for all
sorts of people who aren't inherently
biologists or don't want to be paying
attention this sort of thing to keep
track of all the different types of
things that are currently being called
vaccines but for those of us who are
dealing with
both you know as everyone is a global
crisis
some of which is based in health and
some of which is based in politics
and are trying to be clear
and also don't simply have the position
either
that no vaccines are good i want to stay
away from all of them or anything that
you choose to call a vaccine is good and
therefore shoot me up
that vast middle ground
is actually the scientifically rigorous
place to be and therefore we feel the
need to to talk talk through why both
the mrna and the adenovirus vectored
vaccines that were introduced i think
the adenovirus affected vaccines were
also introduced with covet or did they
yeah pre-exist uh i'm not i can't say
what's been done in other creatures but
but for humans first time for humans i
believe this is right too and certainly
for mrna i mean they were they were
trying some stuff but it wasn't working
um but with regard to the two and i you
know i don't know for missing other
categories but so far we've talked about
four sort of categories of vaccines here
today and the two
categories of vaccines that pre-existed
um
that existed five years ago uh being
dead or parts of virus uh viruses or you
know antigen uh you call them antigen
vaccines this is and i'm
i'm not sure i've heard that but it
makes sense versus live also known as
attenuated vaccines of all of these
there is one and only one um and it is
the original one right is the original
formulation of vaccines i believe right
the attenuated or live vaccines um that
actually appear
given what dr ben's past research has
indicated um and what frankly well more
than a century of research has indicated
to reduce all-cause mortality and those
who receive them right now um
i will say
the work on the
live
attenuated versus the killed virus
vaccines and their relatives i didn't
know that work existed i didn't know
that anybody had done all cause
mortality work and so it's not purely
independent but i will point out
um this is reflective of exactly the
logic that you and i worked our way
towards we figured this out this is what
we predicted and there's one aspect of
this that i didn't predict
um
which is worth pointing out too because
the question is how good is the model
yeah right i didn't predict uh a
all-cause mortality benefit from
generalized administration of um
uh of a
live
virus vaccine okay
i that that's a little surprising to me
right that goes beyond that goes beyond
that target disease yeah so and that
wasn't included in what you said so
there's all-cause mortality that may
increase um because the benefit against
that disease is so high yes um but
all-cause mortality that is not fully
explicable by the benefit of fighting
the target disease right whereas
whereas the
hey there are going to be other effects
you're intervening in a
layered series of complex systems with
a therapy that's going to have multiple
impacts almost all of them negative in
the case of the killed virus adjuvant
vaccines that we did say right that did
seem very likely
and turns out to be turns out to be true
[Music]
you